ما تشير اليه الخرائط هنا خرائط تحركات
القوات الاوكرانيه هو ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تقوم بالاحاطه بمنطقه
بخموت لا تتقدم باتجاه المدينه في عمق
المدينه انما تحيط به منطقه بخمت من
المنطقه الشماليه ومن المنطقه الشرقيه
مجددا نشاهد هذه التعزيزات هنا التي
تقوم القوات الاوكرانيه
ابقائي عليها وبالتوجه من هنا عبر منطقه
غرب باخمت باتجاه منطقه باخم التعزيزات
كثيفه للغايه نشاهدها
تتجه في هذه الاثناء نحو منطقه باكموت
استطيع ان اقول وهنا ايضا نشاهد هؤلاء
الذين يخرجون ايضا من المنطقه اذا هناك
حركه حركه نشطه كما تشاهدون في هذه
الاثناء من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في محيط
منطقه باكموت باتجاهها وعبرها ايضا بعد ما
جرى في الداخل
الروسي بعد انسحاب قوات فاجنر من تلك
المنطقه
ورصدي هذه التحركات في القوات الاوكرانيه
المختلفه في محيط هذه الجبهه هذه الجبهه
عادت لتشتعل مجددا كما يبدو القوات
الاوكرانيه تعزز من مواقعها هناك
والتصريحات الرسميه تشير الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتقدم بهذا الاتجاه